this factory on the outskirts of
freetown
is one of dozens of small and medium
industries that rose from the ashes of
sierra leone civil war
it refines and exports palm oil and
byproducts and in the past two years has
been able to expand its reach to markets
in west africa and asia 45 percent goes
in the local market and the balance we
are exporting to countries like ghana
senegal
liberia and we're trying to explore more
and more countries
the government says focusing on the
country's strengths is key to industrial
growth
and one of the areas which we have tried
to focus on
is agriculture because agriculture is
one area where we can have a whole lot
of raw materials for industry
development
but recovery is slow on many fronts from
rescuing the economy to tackling
corruption and reconciling its people
has his hands chopped off by rebels
during the war
because of the truth and reconciliation
commission that we will forget we will
forgive but we will never forget because
we are carrying the
the the the half
half of the
activities which was done to us
eleven years of civil war killed at
least fifty thousand people and forced
half a million from their homes
one of the bloodiest conflicts started
when rebels attempted to overthrow the
government
as well as rape mutilations and force
used of child soldiers fighting was
often funded by so-called blood diamonds
mined with slave labor one of the
toughest battles of the sierra leone
civil war was fought here when west
african troops battled rebel forces the
air uf then in control of the east of
freetown attempted to push west
this monument and the bridge over there
which is now called the peace bridge
stand as reminders of some of the
darkest chapters in ceremony's history
rebels who fought in the war are also
still struggling two decades on
most of my colleagues some of them are
not coming again to mingle in certain
societies because while they have
already been humiliated they need to
they accept the way the society have
taken them but like me i disaccept the
society
the government admits the reconciliation
process is slow
do you want more speed
but under this administration i think we
have addressed more trc recommendations
than any other administration before
before president bill
sierelion has been stable politically
for the past 20 years but divisions
remain
for now the biggest concern for the
government and citizens alike is
combating corruption
improving infrastructure and reducing
unemployment
all require huge amount of money
something sierra leone doesn't have
despite its vast mineral wealth ahmed
idris al jazeera free town cereal